hey guys  i'm going to try to do a great comedy  set for you all but if it doesn't go  well  i don't really care because comedy is  just my hobby and sales is my passion  sales getting the numbers in the green  it's a pretty good one my name is carmen  christopher and i'm a comedian  and i'm actually excited to announce  that i've never been depressed  the pandemic hit and comedy venues have  closed but i think people still want to  laugh i'm going to take my best material  and i'm going to do it on the streets of  new york city unsolicited  for people who do not even see it coming  you guys  my parents are getting divorced  psych they got divorced 20 years ago  let's party  you